question géographie oui très bien bon
dans quelle ville c'est très simple on
commence doucement quelle ville se
trouve le siège du parlement européen
parlement européen malentendu c'est
assez facile c'est une ville calme
réhabiliter daniel braud car il ya
énormément de ce sofa
et strasbourg une ville
[Applaudissements]
la commission européenne est à bruxelles
à la le parlement dans nulle mais dont
le nombre est jamais en effet acheté à
d'autres questions posées bien sûr
j'étais sûr histoire ce jeu si vous êtes
féru d'histoire
c'est une bête cette
affaire une histoire de recherche et
d'égyptologie bien évidemment qui a été
le roi d'égypte de la vième dynastie de
l'ancien empire égyptien entre -1550 2
et - 1619 on a posé la question sur bien
sûr évidemment qui a été le roi d'égypte
de la vième dynastie de l'ancien régime
de l'ancien empire d'égypte c'était
entre 1622 2000 - 1619 est pas clair
l'avait pas faire
s'imposer je veux dire en plus cela le
problème c'est que je vous dis priorité
au direct à un duplex
je crois
je suis dans les dicos d'or la truite
sort
tu sais bien mais ce qu'il nous est là
en plus dense cockpit à mourir de chaud
j'arrive alors n'oubliez pas surtout
c'est important je suis avec mon
chauffeur de tête c'est le cas s'il
n'aura de tête cyril j'arrive
la voilà
quand des coeurs sont avec nous un
instant donné des nouvelles de la reine
la reine des murs et la reine qui semble
être fier à la
répéter votre question sont bien
évidemment qui a été le roi d'égypte de
la vième dynastie de l'ancien empire
d'égypte je pense que ces raouts est
croyez-moi la prod a foutu 10000
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai pensé si moi je n'ai pas une triste
laval est en train de diriger
la nasa me
suis tant sa littérature parce qu'on
sait que vous pour vous les ratures
c'est extrêmement important à quel
écrivain doit-on 7 cette phrase qui a
beaucoup de sens être pauvre à paris
c'est être pauvre deux fois être pauvres
a permis que c'était peut-être aux
pauvres deux fois ce n'est pas nous n'a
déjà lors
un connard tu aux pêcheurs une amie qui
me reviennent par les gens voient
ce qui se passe dans cet effectif
[Rires]
c'est un bon point
à matignon
ces gens j'en rigole bien sûr séjour
maquilleuse
mais correct dit daniel deschodt wissant
oui je recommence à toi tout seul je
radote des comptes la déglinguer
[Rires]
guillarmé cherisey à bavois n'y a pas
que toi mon genre tu sais pas bon ça va
pas ça va et toi t'en vas tranquille le
moche jour au cimetière de montmartre
où quartier tranquille avec mes potos
chicha a pas trente et un points sinon
on va peut-être se croiser ouais tu
variété d'animaux non droit qui est
michel michez berger et enfin ce sujet
nanti saint émile zola
[Rires]
merci jean saluons d'abord
santé bonheur
évidemment donc à cannes exploitons
cette citation être pauvre à paris c'est
être pauvre deux fois ne serait ce pas
l'excellentissime
emile zola
et surtout
je connaissais très bien sa soeur saola
la luz là où ce
n'est quand même dire qu'à l'époque
d'emile zola qui tue suite ira bien sûr
déjà l'immobilier à paris posé problème
ah oui narry away à je suis lavallière
est vrai mais tu va soulever qu'autre
chose toi